had a little story to share with you
please go ahead a couple of summers ago
three summers ago i visited vermont and
there's one much in the whole state of
vermont the Juma congregation the friday
sermon the friday prayer is probably
about seventy people at the most really
small community and so i went out there
to give some lectures do some programs i
met a young man an albanian young man
and he was he was really struggling a
lot of challenges they had literally
seen their own father killed before
their own eyes him and his two older
brothers and they came here they were
basically living here on their own
working like you know some type of a
night shift like a janitor job somewhere
just trying to get by and unfortunately
they'd fallen into a lot of bad stuff
they were drinking and partying and
gambling and doing all this stuff and
the youngest brother who's probably you
know 18 years old 19 years old right out
of high school he said that one day he
was searching for something I think on
YouTube you are searching for something
about music and you must have done an
episode about something in regard so
related to music and it showed up in
some of the related videos and he
clicked it and started watching it and
he said he got hooked he said he did not
leave the computer for like two days he
just kept coming back kept coming back
and just watching this he said he saw
every single episode that you had ever
recorded and he said it changed his life
and I didn't even know you back then he
introduced me to didn't show but he just
said do you know brother Eddie do you
know brother Eddie I said I don't know
brother Eddie and he showed me the show
and you know I just wanted to let you
know that there's hopefully insha'Allah
he'll watch this episode as well but
there's lots of people out there like
that that I've really benefited so may
Allah bless you and reward you and
accept this blessed effort hamdulillah
all praises to the creator of the
heavens and earth who's given us this
ability to be here and inshallah God
willing inshallah God willing that the
creator of the heavens in her accepts
this robot I mean
I mean